so i was i was raised christian a
catholic
specifically and we were learning all
about
you know the trinity and everything in
school and um
and then this whole atheist period of my
life
happened during my teenage years so i
used to be very dogmatically atheist but
in philosophy it's called atheism proper
which is the proposition that there is
no god
and you hold that belief and you think
you know it i know that there is no god
i didn't take my shahada until i was 24.
like it took me a while
[Music]
um
you're going to waver you're you're a
man is going to go up and down based on
your emotions but that has
nothing to do with the reality right you
could feel that way about your marriage
about your job about your friends about
your co-workers about
your entire life and about your entire
existence that doesn't mean you don't
exist
that doesn't mean you know your
co-workers are bad that doesn't mean
your
your wife is like sneaking off at night
um these are just emotional
uh skeptical moments and there's
something that
you really don't have to pay much
attention to because most likely it
should on
uh behind all of it so seek refuge in
allah increasing quran
and may allah allow us to have strong
iman
assalamu alaikum
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya
featuring yours truly yusuf founders
good how are you from all right before
we begin
let's uh let's merge tap into this insha
allah
i don't think i would give it an uh um a
proper
suited introduction so this is also
featuring tap essentially
yeah yeah so um taps another show
as i i've got my channel which is
pondering soul
and then tap is like a collaboration
between me and a few brothers
says jake who's got a channel called the
muslim metaphysician
and then abdul rahman and sharif who
themselves unfortunately don't have
youtube channels um although i think
they should probably start one because
they're
they're definitely worthy of one and um
yeah and so the four of us just do a
show
pretty much once every but it's supposed
to be once every second sunday
um but certain things sometimes sort of
get in the way of that and maybe it's
a little bit longer but um yeah i think
we've got one that's supposed to be
going on tomorrow
um which i don't know if when how long
it takes you to upload these but it
might have already happened
um and people are watching this but
we're supposed to be discussing the the
subject of
uh why only one god and and why not
polytheism but
it's a really cool podcast we generally
just uh explore certain questions
we'll talk about it for an hour or so
and then start to invite guests on
instagram talk to them yeah do check
that out
thought adventure podcast well it's
adventure podcast
tap so i guess featuring the realist
philosophical podcast in the dunya masha
allah
so without further ado um because the
topic of why only one god is is really
important
um because if you you can follow
certain uh ontological arguments
that lead you to one god right and you
can
deductively come to the conclusion that
this is the only
possible way real reality could exist
because you have multiplicity it doesn't
make sense it's a contradiction if you
don't have one that's a contradiction
so a lot of people don't understand that
one
one god is the only way and two how
important philosophy is it's something
we were discussing recently
so what is philosophy how do we use it
in our everyday life
and why is it important yeah so that
even that question is something
philosophers
debate uh which is funny what is
philosophy so
the greek um root comes from
filos which means the love of
and then sophia which means wisdom says
technically according to the roots the
love of wisdom um
which can also be tied to things like
the pursuit of truth
um and exploring the
the world of arguments i guess and and
dialogue
in order to try to attain that truth or
that wisdom
now how that's played out over the
centuries is you know
very different depending on where you
are um and
it has its benefits but it also has its
dangers as well
um a lot of philosophers end up
suffering from
existential crisis and things like that
uh you know some of the most famous
philosophers um usually it's their
ability to think quite deeply was also
accompanied by a sort of
uh agonizing anguish
of sorts like nietzsche who's um one of
my favorite philosophers not because i
agreed with everything he said i
disagreed with a lot of it um but
he went mad towards the end of his life
uh he he concluded his um
sanity with a cuddle with a horse um
after he saw it being whipped
and uh he he hugged it and said i know
your pain and then from that point on
uh he lost his mind his debate whether
it was because of
the sort of things he was dabbling with
because he spoke about nihilism a lot
um or the gonorrhea that he contracted
um
while he was younger in the army so
but there's a discussion about but yeah
the point is is that philosophy
can't it you know it it's very useful
for certain things a lot of things were
underpinned by even
science as we know it today derived from
that
um and you know it's important in order
to be able to sort of figure out the
major questions about life who you are
what are you doing here um all of these
are philosophical
in nature and do you think it's
important for us to
know why we're here or to even venture
down that path because you'll have a lot
of
new age atheists and and scientists who
argue
why is a dumb question to ask and none
of it really matters
well yeah i would say that
like to refer to the the why questions
as
as silly or as questions that shouldn't
really be asked is itself
a silly notion um you know
they often will allude to the the
the beauty of creation and how it
strikes all in you and
they play on that now this all
that is what is motivating these like
why questions and you know what is going
on how how did i get here how what is
all of this
now they might try to sort of move
from that experience you know the the
awe of creation itself
to this notion of um dead
materialism like the foundation of
everything is just
mechanical and lifeless at its core
and there is no like overarching grand
significance to anything
um but that seems to me to be heavily
imposed
by the people that are pushing that
particular
sort of line of thinking it's they they
already
think that yeah and then they have to
push that onto it because
i think in and of itself and and i
really do believe this is
the most common experiences when you do
look at things like the stars you look
up at the sky you look at things around
you
and you do experience or it's very very
difficult
for the average person to see that being
senseless
yeah i think you know it's to look at it
through the eyes of the
the sort of the dead materialist it
you know it takes a bit of um being
exposed to
certain kind of thinking like that of
richard dawkins or you know his ilk
um but i think intuitively when you're
just going about the majority of people
have the same experience and i think
that you can see
evidence of that even with like the
study of
anthropology richard dawkins himself he
admitted this on a jo rogan podcast
there hasn't been an atheistic society
regardless of where you look in history
where on the planet where in time
all civilizations throughout history
have always had a sense of the divine
a sense of spirituality a connection
with something
transcendental um obviously there's been
differences here and there with regards
to how they conceived a bit but
the notion was the same there is
something significant about
the the universe there is something
significant about existence itself
um and you know that that is common
throughout all
societies throughout history yeah
subhanallah it's found a lot
and a lot of people including myself
actually didn't know that um
and now i'm thinking is it even possible
to have
an atheistic society without something
governing like like
secularism or liberalism because
inevitably as human beings as you talked
about this
this sense of awe when i learned about
it it was
um recognition of greatness and respect
you know to greatness anything we see as
great um and the
desire to sanctify something this is the
reason we see all these societies talked
about sanctified something
but in a liberalistic and secular
society
the object of sanctification becomes you
know oneself
yeah yeah yeah and that's interesting
because
this has got to do with values and what
we value the most
now atheists they don't like to see
themselves
as religious um obviously this is the
whole
like the core of their how they
understanding now
from even from an islamic perspective we
understand worship quite broadly
yeah um in terms of that which you sort
of put at the top
of your value hierarchy will say
and that which you then orient your life
around yeah
and um so even in the quran it says you
know have you seen those who take
themselves as gods
that is you know not just that they they
pray
to themselves or you know they say oh me
can you provide this you know the quran
isn't saying that that's what they do
yeah what it's alluding to is the fact
that you know out of
everything that they have in their lives
that
their own self-interest their own
self their own ego their own love is the
thing they value the most
yeah and you you know and it doesn't
have to be the self you can value things
in the world
and you see this with sort of um the
celebrity worship where like subhanallah
when i don't know if you've ever seen
you know
i hope uh i don't get a lot of flack
from the bts crowd or the you know the
k-pop
fans but the way they treat these
celebrities is akin to a sort of
religious nature
you know their rooms become shrines to
the celebrities that they love they
like they they even seek guidance from
these people like how does this person
live their life
i want to live my life like that it's
it's you know
this is how we treat allah subhanahu wa
in the quran
we go to that to seek guidance to seek
um you know a way of trying to
understand how to
interact with the world that we find
ourselves in and you know
that can be either through you know
celebrity worship
or through um even like
the the worship itself so that they'll
trust their own intuitions
above everything else like oh i don't
like this or i like this
and you know that it gets rather complex
but
we're it's related to this notion of the
fact that we are
somehow innately
so built to to value things and
with that there's always going to be
something at the top of that hierarchy
now if obviously if you don't believe in
god it's going to be other things it's
going to be dunya
it's going to be you know something in
creation is going to be the top of that
um if you're religious it's going to be
something transcendental it's going to
be something higher than that
and with us in particular that's going
to be allah subhanahu wa
yeah um yeah so it's quite interesting
yeah subhanallah
and it would almost it would be
impossible
for a human not to have something like
that because by nature we're
we're people we're habitual people right
where were people with habit and
particular nature so the way we operate
is and this is you know something for
myself take with a grain of salt
but essentially the way we operate is
it's better to have a general guiding
mechanism than to have
like a bunch of random specific rules
right for this situation do this
you know we'd rather go towards a
general
guiding mechanism and we do so
subconsciously
right and this is in the form of
whatever allah has given us our desires
are enough sin all of that
it's only when you use your your
intellect and your wisdom and you really
tap into your fitrah
that you can recognize allah and islam
and really submit to make the conscious
decision
when you're older to submit to that but
without that
you cannot live a life not being
obedient to not
submitting to something even if and and
the term nephs i've heard a lot of
interpretations of it and translations
of it literally meaning
uh like not just the self or oneself
but the desires right so not just
themselves as their own gods
but even more specifically their desires
as their own gods and their desires
would in that case be their guiding
compass subhanallah so yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's it's insane and the problem is
a lot of people
you know don't reflect on these things
nowadays because they're so deeply
tapped into it
yeah well if you think about it so you
you have this desire what is a desire a
desire is
first of all the recognition of a lack
of something you don't have x or y or z
um but you want it you want to attain it
now if that desire or that wish
becomes the the focal point of your life
then you know this is akin to worship
now
when you compare that to say oh this
again now allah his pleasure is
fundamentally that's you know ideally as
well what we're supposed to be
orientating ourselves around
um towards his pleasure ultimately and
we do everything
um you know via the
the desire to please him to worship him
in order to attain his happiness and
inshallah to attain paradise at the end
of that
yeah now when you do that that becomes a
guiding principle for you you
you you can't help but think through
that lens like
what job am i going to do and why am i
going to do it for the sake of allah and
like how
you know obviously am i going to fit
that in now if you're doing things haram
that isn't going to work you can't do
the haram for the sake of allah
so you know this is always a factor and
it's always playing in how you
orient yourselves now you lack that and
but you want things what do you want you
want things money power women
fame recognition whatever it is
that you want these things are going to
be the things that you
are directing your life by and for the
attainment of them and
you know like in the same way the
alcoholic for example
his his major focus his desire his
almost
his god um with the way they treat it is
the attainment of a particular state and
you know
the way he's going to attain that is
through the achieving of alcohol or the
drug addict
um and they'll do things that they
wouldn't usually
do um so the heroin addict might be
willing to rob
people and they'll do this in a state of
desperation and
so i i had um family members that were
addicted to heroin and they would do
these sort of things and otherwise they
were normal people
very likable but in you know when the
desire
became so high on their hierarchy of
values they couldn't think of anything
else whatsoever
um so my funny story
uh my dad he was a heroin addict and uh
one day he was trying to figure out a
way of getting to
this place where he could score and uh
he was walking and one of the neighbors
at the end of our street had left his
car running to warm up the engine
outside of his house and um i know it
doesn't sound funny yet but it gets
funnier
so he he got into the car and nicked it
and then drove off got his stuff
came back packed it outside the guide's
house again and left a little note
saying thank you uh sorry i needed to
borrow your car it was an emergency
and then and got off but for him it was
just like
you know his need to get something just
sort of
overlooked even his um yeah his
you know his place within the community
how like he couldn't really see any more
how that wasn't necessarily a good thing
um and yeah and you see this sort of
obviously it's not to say that all
atheists are like heroin addicts
um but it's just this example of like
when something is your highest value how
you act from that and that the the
atheists themselves
they can't get rid of that they still
have to have things that they value the
most
the question is is now what is that now
obviously if they're not
religious this notion of what they can
place at the top of that is
by necessity very chaotic it could be
anything yeah
and so it can be hard to sort of
classify it by the nature of the fact
that
it can be anything from celebrities from
um power from money from you know like
xyz you can just place whatever
thing it is that they happen to value
the most there um but but it has to be
there
there has to be something they value the
most what is that is the question
and it's going to be quite individual
yeah it's it's actually kind of funny
because for some atheists it's still
god right it's just the the concept the
belief
and the it's like it's like a um a form
of identification for them
right that god doesn't exist so it's
it's this thing that
doesn't exist that they they kind of
worship so much and they
push like richard dawkins i think the
most
per the person who's the most obsessed
with the idea of god or
god not existing are atheists all right
like their life is still oriented around
god yeah
we're watching a joe rogan podcast and
they were like do you believe in like
a creation force like pro to say god
yeah yes it's like they'll try to put
anything in there like
was it aliens is it a computer program
are we in the matrix is it like
elon musk period point blank like
believe in god he's like
i believe there is an answer for why
we're here like come on bro
yeah there's there is a creative force
so
you you can categorize these certain
elements and they just have to a lot of
times to be
many of the attributes of allah
subhanahu talaha um but yeah it's really
funny and it i guess it's important here
to make a distinction as well
i think the majority of the majority of
people
are indifferent so like in
probably the same in are you both in
canada or
yeah yeah um i can guess it's probably
not that
different where you are to like in
england but um so where i grew up was
like a council estate
um which is basically just a government
funded
housing area where people that were on
low incomes or single parents or
whatever they would go into these places
and a lot of it was
funded by government and what you find
in these
estates is that generally it's got a lot
of problems so there's a lot of people
that are
like addicted to drugs or alcohol and
there's a lot of single parents there's
a lot of
um you know like children that don't
really
have fathers around in their lives
because they're either just not around
at all or they're in and out of prison
or they're you know they're dead
um or whatever and in these environments
god isn't really a common topic
like generally it's not very often
people
talk about god more times they're
talking about
the dunya life like what they want to do
you know
the things that they admire the
celebrities that they are interested in
um you know you can get corny ones like
the bts
sort of k-pop followers where we were
that wasn't
like a common sort of thing it was more
rap and hip-hop
and uh we have um garage
i don't know if you you're familiar with
garage it was like uh
english form of rap um on with something
called um
can you remember all of the names
dubstep
like yeah so these you know were the
things that everyone was obsessed with
and festivals
um and a conversation would generally
go around that and the only time maybe
religion would come up
is when we would see like the crazy
preacher you know the bible
person that was usually stood on a box
and he was saying you're all going to
hell
and it was always associated with say
like the comedy films we'd watched um
so there was a lot of media being
produced that was sort of ridiculing the
notion of religion
ridiculing the notion of religiosity
and we would and it's obviously in
hindsight now you see that but you can
see how this
these films and this media and a lot of
it was comedy so
you know it would make you laugh and
like if it gets you laughing
as a child um you obviously you're gonna
like it and it sticks
because it's you know the way that
they're presenting the media it really
really um
sinks in and so we were always
associating
the nature of the religious person with
that with
this weird thing and it wasn't until i
was about maybe 17
um when i started sort of me like
you know i grew up i exited the
the secular schooling system and i was
working now and i was with
real people um and i started meeting
religious people and they weren't
like that they weren't these crazy weird
people the majority of them were all
quite
normal and you could sit down and have
nice conversations with them and
interesting conversations with them and
a few of them were happen to be muslim
so we used to
um go shisha cafes and things like that
uh when we were a lot younger 17 18. and
i would ask them all these awkward
questions you know the typical things
that people bring up when they're
learning about islam like oh well this
says this in the quran it says that in
the quran
what about this hadith what about that
hadith and uh
they were very patient with me and
children like how did i get
to that sorry i go on these talking
about how
people just don't want to believe in god
and then oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so it's i was in that state so
um and
you know somehow experiencing normal
religious people
was weird for me and like trying to get
my head around these things and
i used to be very dogmatically atheist
and like
in philosophy it's called atheism proper
which is the proposition that there is
no god
and you hold that belief and you think
you know it i know that there is no god
um which is what i would say an atheist
is
um and then you have like lesser forms
of atheism or like
agnostic atheism where they're like they
just say they don't believe but
um you know they're not 100 sure if
there is one or not
and then that even goes into different
categories is it because you
think that it's impossible to know or
just it may be possible to know you just
haven't
sort of come across these answers so
this is spectrum but the majority of
people are
i would say um apathetic
or just uninterested and it's if it's a
conversation it's
generally in terms of like how it humors
them
or it's a form of comedy i mean let me
ask you this
if there was an atheist in the room and
he told you that
you know you're like sitting across from
him and he said you got five minutes to
convince me
that god exists what would you say
subhanallah i'm putting it on the spot
yeah yeah yeah time starts now go
well i would say i don't know if it's
something you can convince someone in
five minutes
like for me it wasn't five minutes for
me
so i was raised christian a catholic
specifically and we were learning all
about
you know the trinity and everything in
school and um
and then this whole atheist period of my
life
happened during my teenage years
and then i started talking about it
properly when i was about 17.
i didn't take my shahada until i was 24
and i think i read the quran maybe twice
in that time
i'd read a lot about the life of the
prophet muhammad about
the sahaba and i'll be pleased with the
more i went and stayed in buddhist
temples
in like i was like it took me a while
like it didn't take me five minutes and
i think it's all of these sort of
experiences and
looking at the world and looking into
these religions and
having conversations with interesting
people that you know
it chips away at you bit by bit by bit
and
it's incremental steps i don't think
you're ever going to convince anyone in
five minutes
what about people that say am i just not
guided
there's a lot does does god just not
want to guide me why can't i
you get me yeah well that can be the
case um
but i would say sometimes a lot of it's
sort of tied to the kind of life
we choose to live now there's a lot of
things that go on
behind closed doors the people you know
allah knows
what's hidden in the deepest parts of
our hearts you know we all have these
parts of us that we keep secret these
thoughts that we don't talk to people
about
um we maybe these conversations
like we're very complex beings there's a
lot going on with
people and there may be
certain problems or certain habits that
you just refuse to give up that you
really should do
that act as an impediment to your
we'll call it spiritual sight i guess um
so that you know and like allah says in
the quran it's um
they i did not wrong them but they
wronged themselves that is allah isn't
wrong in them they
maybe act or do certain things and
that is something that can what we we
would say
from the islamic perspective would be to
that clouds the fitra that makes it
difficult to see
and that can be anything from just
engaging in things like
alcohol too much and you know taking
drugs or smoking weed
or smoking cigarettes or just chasing
women
now what's usually the case is
when these things which are bad for you
and i would say an impediment um
to the fitra um usually what happens is
there has to be a development of a
dislike for these things or
um it's not necessary but most of the
time
you have to begin you get to a point
where you start to hate these things
for whatever reason because you you you
go into it naively have you ever seen
pinocchio i love this example
you know pinocchio do you remember
pleasure island
don't remember you know you watch
pinocchio you don't remember pleasure i
am
yeah yeah honestly right so pinocchio's
the little wooden boy
and he wants to be a real boy and they
he's walking down the road with some of
the lad and this fox
and the slimy character comes up to him
he's like oh have you heard of pleasure
island we're going there you want to
come
he's like pleasure island and he's a
young naive boy and we are all that
at one point in lives we're all these
young silly naive boys we're ignorant
we don't know about the world and
we inclined you know like my daughter
for example
she's like give me ice cream give me
icing she just wants if she could she'd
just
live off ice cream and sweets and to her
that's like
the best thing ever and if someone came
along to her and said would you like to
live off
ice cream and sweet she'd just jump
straight on that she'd say yeah
and like when i tried to get in the way
of that and stop that i said no no
come on you gotta eat healthy food if
you want to grow up
to be like a healthy human being without
black teeth like you know you've gotta
sometimes do things that you don't like
and restrain from the things that you do
like
it's just but at that early stage in
life it's hard to see that
um and this this man or these men
are taking advantage of that naivety in
these young people and inviting them to
this place
called pleasure island which as you can
probably tell from the name um
is just this place filled with pleasure
like they get to live
hedonistically they can do what they
want and it's just like a huge fun
ground so they get to drink they get to
smoke
they get to break things they can play
pool they can do all of these things
and there's no one telling them not to
do it so there's vandalism and
fights and fires and like everything
whatever they want they get to do
um and they they think it's a good thing
they think it's a good thing
but then what happens is slowly they
start to turn into donkeys
are you familiar with is it striking a
memory at all or
can you still not remember it was it
that long ago so they literally turn
into donkeys
and it's it works really well as an
analogy to life because
that is what happens and that's
certainly what happened
to me and what i saw happening to people
all around me
and still happening to today in that
we are told or you know we sold this
story about
um you know the western ideals about you
know liberalism freedom
um you know like do what makes you
quote-unquote happy
and but there's no there's not much
discussion about the distinction between
what happiness or true happiness is or
being content
living a fulfilled life with just
pleasure seeking as a kid these things
aren't explained to you
and you just sort of see them as the
same thing a happy life is one filled
with pleasure
but then you you engage in these things
which
cause pleasure and you keep doing it to
the point where
the the effects diminish where they
become like
there is no feeling anymore there is no
pleasure like for anyone who's drunk
the first drink always gets you wasted
like
my family are all scottish and so i
think i the first time i got drunk was
in 2000
i'd have been maybe even younger than
that
but i remember the first memory of
properly getting drunk was the
millennium
we were in scotland everyone was
celebrating it and they gave me a
budweiser
and and me and my brother were running
around and we were off our head on a
couple of budweiser
and that was just one and then as you
get older and you sort of acclimatize to
it you need more and you need more and
you need more
as a guy i know now he's in his 60s
he'll go out and he'll
drink something like 18 pints and he's
not
unconscious it just doesn't make any
sense but he's been drinking so long
that his tolerance has increased to the
point where he needs more of it and it's
the same with everything
yeah very good you want to say something
no i was going to say it's like
psychologically you just want to
recreate that first high
or that first bit yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you keep chasing it
like with heroin as well it's they they
say that it's called
you're just chasing the first experience
and it's like um for heroin in
particular they describe it as like
being kissed by god
over blood it's but you know they they
just
for them it's such an experience that
they can't explain it
without having to refer to the best
thing they can imagine
and then every attempt to get there
always fails
and they always require more and more
and more and more in order to get that
first thing and
it's the same with things like chasing
women um you know like that first
experience of being with a girl
it you know it's exciting it's this it's
that um
but then like a lot of the time
especially young men in the west
that this this ideal of women
is generally shaped by heavy pornography
use from a very early age like we were
exposed to
um pornographic magazines from in
primary school
so i had been maybe even like nine at
the time
and um and then the internet comes in
and this is as a young man you've got
all of these chemicals pumping through
you know you start to hit puberty and
then you just have like
unlimited access to the internet the
generation that is looking after us
is clueless about what on earth is going
on on the internet like it's new to
everyone
so they don't know what's happening and
we've just got this
access to it and it's it's developing in
a particular culture within the youth
where like
and the the parents just had no idea
about it why because it's
an embarrassing thing to talk to your
parents about you just not
you know like as if anyone's going to be
telling a man about the things that
they've been looking at on the internet
but it develops this strange little
culture it develops how you you see
women
and and what you end up doing is women
become a game
and like obviously depending on who you
are
like you have maybe the the ones that
weren't necessarily able to even talk to
women and you get the development of
this sort of in-cell
quote-unquote culture um which is the
people that just sort of talk on the
internet about how they wish they could
get them in
and generally again it's sort of talked
about in a particular manner
or you get the people who you know are
at least a little bit confident enough
to be able to do that
um so you know to seek women and at
least
be somewhat successful with them and
what you find is that it never really
lives up to the expectations it's never
quite like
that first experience and
you know the lust is there to begin with
but it dies down it fades out
and you know they confuse this feeling
of lust of this ecstasy this excitement
with love and they'll refer to it as
love oh i'm in love with this girl oh
she's amazing and then what they're
describing is basically just being
just really really desiring someone that
and that isn't love
that's wanting what you don't have yeah
but then the problem with that is is
when you have it it loses its effect
and you know that isn't that's not love
that's something completely different
it's like um
you know the aftershave if you ever walk
past someone i use the same examples a
lot so anyone who's so familiar with
me on youtube is gonna have heard this a
lot anyway um
but when you walk past someone and
they've got an aftershave you've not
smelt before but it's like
that's banging that i want it well and
you have to ask him what what are you
wearing
and you love it and then you get it and
you wear it and you're like yeah
i smell sick and then after a bit of
time
like you can't smell it anymore and it
gets annoying and you're like i've just
sprayed someone's
you know after wearing it for a while
you have to like pretty much
swim in it but like you can't smell it
it just doesn't have the effects you
either have to what
go to a new aftershave or keep putting
more and more aftershave on
um generally you'll maybe switch it up
and you'll try a new smell
and you know with youth um
where i came from um i don't know what
it's probably
very much the same everywhere in the
west with young men
this is just you know if you have the
ability to drift from woman to woman
then
generally that happens it's very very
very rare you see
long lasting relationships in youth
yeah you don't see that you see short
you know up down relationships where
it's like
super super high they sort of make gods
out of each other they idolize each
other they
see each other as perfect and then they
make this ideal
of each other so high that neither is is
destined to fail because neither can
live up
to this sort of perfect character that's
been made of them
they all have flaws you know like they
fart
they stink sometimes maybe they get
nervous and sweaty
maybe they you know say something
strange
um or they make a mistake and then like
when any of these flaws sort of appear
this image especially with young people
i'm talking about teenagers here
that image just shatters and it goes
from like oh they're the perfect person
to
the worst person ever the enemies it's
you know like
it's it's rare you see like a chilled
breakup
where someone's not like completely
distraught
um yeah it's upon her sorry
i go on rambles feel free to uh
[Music]
nowadays we really we romanticize the
idea of romance
right we romanticize the idea of being
with someone
in a like you like you mentioned like
you described like in this perfect sense
and we set up these ex i think the the
the best way i could summarize it
personally is having no expectations of
yourself
but insane expectations of the other and
now you have two people who expect so
much from the other
but have no expectations or standards
for themselves
yeah that something like that obviously
as you said is bound to fail and
subhanallah
it's because people are they're looking
for the wrong things they're looking
at the wrong things and they're looking
for the wrong things
by definition happiness is just a
feeling right it's a feeling of
excitement
and all this stuff but contentment is a
state
it's a state of happiness so what should
we really be chasing
right if you're chasing happiness it's
just a constant
you know that moment but if you're
chasing contentment
or if you're working towards contentment
you're working towards being
in a state of happiness
just as you are it's not even it's like
so there's something important it's
distinct from happiness
so life is ups and downs yeah now
contentment
is the ability to be able to even
experience the downs
and still be chilled about it yeah like
you know being upset
being sad isn't the end of the world for
you
like you're you're able to keep yourself
composed
yeah even in those moments now someone
who isn't content
they'll be dragged around like a dog on
a leash when they're both happy
and when they're sad when they're happy
it's like
you know life is perfect it's never
going to end
and the loss of that if you're not
content if you're content you're wary of
happiness
you're like you know yeah it's here but
you're you're realistic in the sense
that you know it's
it'll fade something will happen uh it's
not going to be here forever
and so you don't you know you might be
able to
feel it and enjoy it when it arises but
you don't
attach yourself to it to the degree that
you just sort of
you know you expect it to be there
forever because that's not what life is
life is not you know life ultimately
ends in death
yeah like even whoever you love
you know be that your mother your father
your your wife
your children all of them die
eventually you know it's it's sad
and the older you get the sadder the
life can become
because you know you become ill as you
get older you become more decrepid
you hit a peak and then you decline
you know that is the inevitable story
it's not
as you know all of these fairy tales put
it it's not always a happy ending
yeah it's um and to be content
is to sort of see that that is the end
of things
but that is the reality of life that
life isn't just
happiness it's also suffering
and so allow yourself to to recognize
it's an optimistic realism in a sense
that you you know
yeah these things are gonna happen yeah
it's gonna suck when they do
um and yeah it's nice when good things
happen
and i'll enjoy it but contentment is
just to sort of
take a step back from this rollercoaster
of ups and downs
and to just allow yourself to experience
them without
you know sort of holding on to them um
or you know making too much of a big
deal out of them
and it's difficult most people have just
sat on that roller coaster and like
you know when they get up to the top
they want it to stay there forever and
you know when they get to the bottom
they want it to end and they'll try and
do whatever they can to make it and
whereas the one who's content
whenever they're at the bottom they're
not they don't act desperate in order to
make that feeling cease you know they're
not doing
silly things like we're moving back to
the example of the teenage love
experience for example
the boy or the girl who idolizes their
partner
and then the partner gets bored of them
and dumps them it's like nah
you know i don't fancy you no more um
that's it
and it breaks their heart they become
pathetic
and like i've done this there's been
girls who have done it with me
i know friends who have done this like
where they just
they they are not themselves and they
make themselves into this
really like lower pathetic version of
themselves where they'll
they'll do any obviously there's a few
lads or girls that probably have never
done this
but they're a minority they're like the
the peak
quote-unquote in terms of um ability to
choose
but you know you become pathetic and
you'll
beg please be with me or you you see
this
in youth and um it's
yeah subhanallah yeah you know
it's it's this idea of like you want to
escape this negative feeling
so much that you'll do anything to get
out of it
and you sort of you think that happiness
lies in this person
and so you know you flock and think but
obviously this is extremely distasteful
um for the person that's experiencing
you
like begging them that's not attractive
it's in any way whatsoever
so it never works um but yeah
yeah subhanallah um yeah that one hits
old man i feel that one
um i've honestly i've been there and it
really
i did not that's why i'm so much man
that's why i love islam so much because
the prophet i said um
he said remember often you know the
destroyer of all desires he didn't just
say that
he said the destroyer of all desires now
why did he say that
because he knows what we're living for
or this the story of all pleasures
um he knows what we're living for is is
you know these pleasureful moments this
is what people cling to
especially in this kind of society
because you make yourself
you know your as we said before your god
your guiding compass what you want you
should get
you know me myself and i that's what
matters so when you have that as your
mechanism
and the only thing is guiding you to is
your your desires and your pleasures
you're bound to be succumbed by those
and by those moments those highs and all
that and when you become that short-term
gratification seeking person the
long-term doesn't matter
so long-term you messed up but when
you're content
and this is the things before we end off
contentment to me just seems like not
expecting too much not wanting too much
not desiring too much
and like subhanallah it's amazing
because again that's what islam
just tells us to do to detach from the
dunya i heard this beautiful hadith of
the prophet i said
he went up to this rotting goat carcass
and he picked it up by the ear and he
said who wants to buy this from me and
the sahaba are like you know
why would we want to buy that we
wouldn't even want it for free he's like
you don't want this
like no why would he want it and long
story short the prophet saw he said that
this in your eyes allah views the dunya
as even less than what you view this
carcass as
we are chasing it we're getting
depressed over it we are running after
it
subhanallah like like our lives depend
on it
yeah well this it all turns to dust
all goes back in the box eventually and
you can't take it with you when you're
dead and um
yeah so i think this is like one of the
key things
with like islam and you know with
religion in general is
with this notion of spirituality is is
generally is
a recognition of the
how everything turns to dust how you can
sort of chase things
and if you're doing it in and off itself
it means nothing at the end and it can
only
mean something via something greater
than
it all of it and you know so by doing
things for the sake of allah
um or you know when you recognize the
the highest sort of level of uh
contentment it's insane attained
um through a desire for the pleasure of
allah
then the dunya becomes something much
easier to deal with you know it's um
it's something you can chill with you're
going to get things you're going to lose
things
you know it doesn't matter i'm aiming
for something that's
you know more lasting something that
doesn't corrode something that doesn't
turn to dust or rot
like that that goat carcass that you
mentioned
some are unconditional yeah exactly
i mean i mean i mean i mean all right
for this amazing episode may allah bless
you guys make sure to like share
comment subscribe and look forward to
the next episode coming soon with
brother yusuf insha'allah
up and down based on your emotions but
that has nothing to do with the reality
right you could feel that way about your
marriage about your job about your
friends about your co-workers about
your entire life and about your entire
existence that doesn't mean you don't
exist
that doesn't mean you know your
co-workers are bad that doesn't mean
your
your wife is like sneaking off um these
are just
emotional uh skeptical moments
and there's something that you really
don't have to pay much attention to
because most likely it's shut on
uh behind all of it so seek refuge in
allah increasing quran
and may allah allow us to have strong
iman
[Music]
[Music]
um